i was watching um who's that really
famous uh comedy and also director guy
in japan he's not always on that
billboard in chiba um
i saw him and he was on japanese tv and
he was reacting to this thing and it was
like lgbt
stuff i've never seen such minimal
reaction in my life he was like a
bulldog just like
and then it cut to a guy in an onsen
giggling and he was like
and i was like well i think i know what
he likes
i don't care for this nonsense get that
off you know it was just it was just
funny
he was just like why why there's like
eight hosts and they refused to take the
camera off him it was just let's keep
him i think that'll take you to those at
the point where
he's done as long as he's on the show
people it doesn't matter
it's just the main brand yeah it's name
so do you want to explain to the
audience who
i guess like beat takashi as he's called
okay
yeah is he's founded takeshi's castle
and that's where name comes from but
originally he was a japanese comedian
and he's basically the reason why
the whole jesus christ you're right what
are you doing
i'm trying to talk about the attack you
[ __ ] that is drink this up
anyway sorry i mean anyway so yeah so
he was like he basically founded the
whole japanese comedy scene back in the
70s
and he's the big reason why there was no
comedy before him
not in tokyo really yeah no no jokes
allowed no so in the so
the hallway he invented
[Music]
the whole idea of like manzai stand up
comedy which is a very like japanese
form of stand-up comedy where it's like
you know
[Laughter]
so basically like the whole it's called
monze which is like there's usually one
mic in the middle
and two people standing in front of one
mic you know doing a whole comedy
routine
and that was really big in osaka or like
in kansai
region and stand-up comedy well yeah
it's a little bit different to just
stand up comedy because a lot of
stand-up comedy at least in the west is
usually like
one person yeah right like it's just one
person kind of telling an anecdote
and then throwing a joke within the
anecdote right like that's
you know very general stand-up comedy
but manzai is kind of like that
but if you split the anecdote and the
jokes into two different people
so basically there's one guy who sets up
the joke and then there's one
guy in there yeah who throws the punch
line and then the guy who sets up the
joke
reacts to the joke and it's that whole
dynamic is it like two-person rakugo
essentially yeah so like rakugo is more
similar to
western stand-up comedy in that sense
because dakugo is all about like telling
an anecdote and then throwing in a
punchline at the end rakugo just seems
like stand-up comedy hard mode
because like imagine stand-up comedy but
you have to sit in this one place and
you can't move and you have limited like
body movements right exactly but like
rocky goes like so [ __ ] ancient in
japan like
it's been doing it since like i don't
even know how long but it's very very
all formal comedy but basically
the whole manzai type of comedy really
originally started in like the 50s and
60s
but basically that was only really a
scene that existed in all sucker and
that's why like a lot of
comedians they're all famous they're all
from osaka i do i've noticed they all
speak in kansai dialect right
and but uh beat takeshi and his group he
was in
he was in a duo called tubito and he was
basically the first
like really big manzai act to make it
big in the tokyo scene
and it was because of his success that
manzai moved
to tokyo as well and like the tokyo area
so that's why he's kind of just known as
like
yeah he's basically the godfather of
like tokyo monster he's also a very good
director
and actor fireworks yeah yeah yeah
they put me in ghost of the shell movies
the dude's done everything
like he like paints he directs he's like
he developed his own game
was he in the original battle royale as
well yes oh yeah of course yeah yeah
that was one of his biggest roles yeah
he's pretty good in that he's really
good he's a great actor yeah he's a very
funny
well i'm just [ __ ] eating chicken and
broccoli every night not achieving
anything
where's your mammoth yeah where's my
mind i didn't realize he was a comedian
that's so yeah director it's quite weird
because
he's comedian but he's also this
incredibly stoic yeah i noticed
that yeah he's very like not called
expression i can't imagine him being a
comedian because
in every film he's played he's like
super serious
right right like yeah you watch you
watch some like old like 70s footage of
him while he was still in
tsubito and he's just the most he was
actually the guy who
was like responsible for like telling
the part of the joke so he was always
the like kind of the clown on the show
right so it's really weird now watching
like ghosts in the show watching this
like
hard face seriously yes i am the badass
in this movie
just [ __ ] going to be like yeah i'm
the clown it's just
i don't know i find it really cool do
you like the movie
likes a strong word okay i guess though
it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay what were you talking about live
action okay i liked it
as [ __ ] i liked it if it wasn't a ghost
in the short movie
why is it [ __ ] chris it's so boring
original anime films right that's what
i'm saying as a ghost in the show movie
it was really bad
but as a just a standalone like sci-fi
movie it was okay
i thought it was i i i literally walked
out of the theater
really yeah because did you yeah i was
very unbritish of you
or just because you're like bored i was
just so bored i was really bored it was
it wasn't i haven't watched it it wasn't
good it obviously wasn't good but it
wasn't
offensively bad so what's the what's
like premise the film by the way for
like i have no [ __ ] clothes
i i know ghost in the shell but i
haven't it's basically the first movie
but with a bit of a twist yeah what
do you know about ghost in the shell
i've watched all of standalone complex
okay so you basically know
the best parts of ghost in the shell
okay don't worry about the movie it's
just a real
standalone complex smash it into two
hours and take away
all the interesting things okay and you
walk down huh and you walked out of that
yeah
well how far in where you walked down oh
i was like did you get to like the the
first fight scene like with the
invisible guy
yeah yeah yeah i got like 45 minutes
late
before i realized i'm like i'm about to
fall asleep now yeah
yeah that's that was probably the first
45 minutes was probably the best part of
the movie like
uncomfortable though the seats aren't
comfortable though
the second half the way that the movie
just ended where they were just kind of
throwing in the whole like cultural
thing was just [ __ ] i feel scared to
hansen was very well cast
no actress but like not not for that
role yeah not
she are you like i really respect
scarlett johansson as an actress but she
just
really she it felt like she didn't care
at all there was like no acting like no
one really gave a [ __ ] like i get you
you're supposed to be a cyborg but
you know yeah put a little bit more she
did that a bit
too well yeah like sorry director when
so
you're a robot right now and she's like
say no more
i understand yeah i don't remember much
about that movie which is i
told you i've only walked out of one
movie uh in the cinemas and that was uh
dragon ball level who shows she watched
that in cinemas i would not walk out of
that movie i would be like
i would be having a great time watching
dragon ball ever i thought so too
because i watched the trailer and i was
like god this looks like [ __ ]
and then it was so much more boring than
i thought it wasn't even like it wasn't
like the so bad that it was good level
it was just
really i thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious i think it's hilarious wait
chris have you walked out of a movie
theater
i've never walked out of a movie theater
i mean this is the only one there was
one that i just
stopped caring really about like very
close that's life in general
downsizing with uh oh my god man david
that's a terrible film
i couldn't work out what was going on if
it was a comedy if it was a drama
it was just it's all over the place okay
but like how many times have you been to
the cinema by yourself
uh a lot i used to go all the time yeah
you should go like once a week in london
because like if you're seeing a film of
mates like you can't yeah you're there
for better or worse even if you may drag
you to this shitty [ __ ] adam sandler
comedy
like whatever yeah i mean okay one i
would watch this shitty adam sandler
movie but
uh i mean if i've planned to do it it's
normally in the evening and i want to
admit
that my evening was was tarnished by
this film because i'm still going to
enjoy the popcorn no matter what right
like and
maybe i get a little nap in as well
might text my feed my mates tell them
about it
i'm [ __ ] it thanks chris being like
chris when we clapping this film sucks
dude i don't know like
i i i rarely go to cinemas anyway so
why i love cinemas i love them yeah it's
just something nice and relaxing and
when you
especially in japan like in the uk
people just throw popcorn and it's a
[ __ ] mess i mean this is
horrible popcorn's so good in japan as
well like there's rarely films that i
think
yeah i need to go see this now no i
don't think that was any of the films i
watched i just think like i want to go
to the cinema because i want the
partnerships you just want the
experience
and i like the experience i like sitting
down like a tenant i did
i really well i haven't seen it now
well i mean it's special considering
there's nothing out right now i thought
it was nice to watch i'm not watching
the demon slavery
if i understood japanese then i would go
to the cinema
so much more often right because i love
watching anime movies because i'm
actually in
they have tons of foreign films though